[Music]
g'day I'm James Tanton and I'm
absolutely thrilled to be with you for
this series and to share with you what I
believe to be a key component to joyful
mathematics success the art of being
visual they say a picture can speak a
thousand words well in mathematics a
picture can spawn a thousand ideas a
picture can provide deep understanding a
picture can prompt that aha moment to
cause an idea or process to suddenly
make sense a picture can lead to finally
understanding a tricky piece of
mathematics and that's what this course
is about I will just share an
alternative way in to the subject a way
to think about topics and see truly see
what they are really about and how to
make them work for you now the ideas can
be elementary or they could be advanced
it really does not matter all
mathematics all levels of mathematics is
thought about with intentionality
naturally lead to beautiful clever and
powerful ideas whether simple study of
counting or studying of tricky
probability theory every piece of
mathematics serves as a portal for
further thought and wonder in this
course I will show you how the story of
visual thinking in mathematics is a very
personal one for me I grew up in
Australia in my mathematical training in
my case 212 days was it particularly
enlightened this was back in the 70s we
were taught algorithms arithmetic
algorithms in primary school algebra
algorithms in high school and so on and
I got the message loud and clear that my
job was just to do and not to question
but I want to know why these algorithms
worked I want to know why negative times
negative is positive
other than just being told it is I want
to know why all the patterns and
Pascal's triangle work the way they do
and so on but I learned early on I was
not to ask questions my job was just to
perform and perhaps your experience was
similar to mine
you two want to know why we all thank
heavens that mathematics education is
much more enlightened today but there is
something in me that compelled me to
make sense of things nonetheless I had
pictures the very early grades in my
schooling were all about pictures we
drew shapes and counted dots we did all
sorts of wonderful visual things all
good stuff but then mat has changed from
grade 4 onwards for me working with
pictures was no longer considered valid
no longer valid mathematics their status
changed that of simplistic tool suitable
only for the very young our job is now
to think analytically through equations
and numbers on the page and not visually
but something in me kept hold of visual
thinking nonetheless privately in my
mind I knew for me pictures were a key
to understanding even for the
mathematics given only in equations and
words so let me show you what I mean
here are some examples from basic
arithmetic ok division I remember in my
early grades certainly groups of dots
and pictures to make sense of division
example the division problem 18 divided
by 3 is asking how many groups of 3 can
you find in a picture of 18 dots well
there are six of them super 18 divided
by 3 is 6 and then I remember years
later having the realization that I can
push this visual picture further and
makes this a sense of some complicated
division problems for example 808
divided by 98 I could just see it had to
be 8 through the remainder of 24 here's
what my brain imagined we're looking for
groups of a hundred rather than 98 the
number da da is just too hard for me to
fathom so look for groups of 100 instead
and we can see there'll be 8 of these
groups with 8 dots left over ah but each
group of 100 is itself off by 2 dots we
wanted groups of 98 after all so we have
an extra 16 dots floating around as well
so that makes for eight groups of 98 and
remainder of 16 and eight that is a
remainder of 24 dots
808 divided by 98 is a
with a remainder of 24 just like I said
I could see it subtraction when asked to
do 34 take away 18 I could certainly do
the standard algorithm and get the
answer 16 but can't we just see in our
minds the answer just has to be 2 plus
10 plus 4 which is 16 line up a row of
34 blocks and a row of 18 blocks side by
side and now we can see the two rows
differ by 2 and 10 and 4 blocks the
difference is 16 in the same way a
thousand twelve take away 797 just has
to be 3 and 212 that's 215 can you see
that 1797 to 800 is 3 800 to a thousand
is another 200 and the extra 12 gets me
to 215 and total actually this
flexibility of thought helps subtraction
in general for example look at 1005 take
away 387 all right in the classic way of
doing this we have a lot of borrowing to
do here that as we observe you 5 take
away 7 requires a borrower 0 take away 8
requires a borrow 0 take away 3 yet
another borrow but we can make this work
simpler so here we're looking for the
difference between 1005 dots and 387
dots so let's make the 1005 friendlier
and turn it into a thousand just remove
5 from each pile and let's just compute
the difference between 1,000 and 382
instead now I can see in my head the
Arts has to be 8 and 10 is 680 up to 390
10 to go to 400 600 to get up 2000 total
of 618 ah but if I don't trust my head
and still want to do the traditional
algorithm then I suggest we move one
more dot from each pile and make the
problem 999 takeaway 381 now I can do
the algorithm out any boards whatsoever
9 take away one fine 9 take away 8 no
problem 93 piece of cake I've made the
problem so much easier to do even
someone insists that I use the Algar
them fine multiplication isn't
multiplication really a geometry problem
isn't 24 times 13 say just asking for
the area of a rectangle that's 24 units
wide and 13 units high then why not just
chop the rectangle to pieces that are
much more manageable for example think
of 24 as 20 and 4 and 13 as 10 and 3
then I can see that 24 times 13 must be
the areas of the individual pieces added
together there's 200 there's 40 there's
a 60 and a 12
that's 312 this type of visual thinking
is only the beginning the very beginning
these are pictures to go with grade
school arithmetic but we can Mullen and
tweak these pictures further and we'll
see how they can provide gateways to so
much more
for example our picture of
multiplication can be used to make
perfect sense of why negative times
negative is positive and we'll do that
in a bit later in the course and we can
make sense of expanding brackets an
algebra class which then takes us to
advanced ideas such as connecting
Pascal's triangle to algebra and which
will then take the results of statistics
and so on each picture we draw like I
said serves as a portal to so much more
we'll see this over and over again
throughout this course for some reason
visual thinking was in my bones from the
get-go and I actually think I know why
back in Australia back in those days in
the 60s and 70s my family owned an old
Victorian house it was my childhood home
and each room of the house had a pressed
tin ceiling and each headed to some
decorative design on it and put it on in
some way and this included my bedroom
and I spent each and every night of my
childhood falling asleep staring at the
design on my bedroom ceiling and the
designer had a mind room was
particularly striking it was just a 5x5
grid of squares though the edges were
vines the corners were little flowers
but in the end I was just staring at a
grid of 25 squares each and every night
and what as a young lad do standard a
grid of squares each night we start
counting things
he starts counting interesting things he
makes up puzzles and mind games based on
that grid of squares and I remember my
very first mathematics surprise coming
from counting on that grid is this one
clearly there are 25 little 1 by 1
squares in the grid but we can count 2
by 2 squares as well and there are lots
of those I end up counting 16 in total
and then I counted the 3x3 squares and
it turns out to be 9 of those in the 4
by 4 squares there are 4 of those and
finally there is one big 5 by 5 square
now look at these counts 25 1 by 1
squares 16 2 by 2 squares 9 3 by 3
squares for 4x4 squares and 1 5 by 5
square each count 25 16 9 for 1 each
count of squares is itself a square
number and I found this striking I found
it surprising and I want to know the why
behind the strange tautology counting
squares on a square grid gives square
number answers and it took me a long
while to figure out how to explain what
was going on my epiphany was to focus
I'm about to give it away was to focus
on the lower left corners of the squares
I was counting for example of the 2x2
squares here are some possible lower
left corners now let me draw all the
possible lower left corners and now I
see that there's a square array of them
4 times 4 of them in fact
that's 16 thus there are 16 2 by 2
squares this image just made it clear to
me why the countless squares is always
sure to be a square number very exciting
but there's one puzzle I made up for
myself on this grid that I truly believe
made me a mathematician it was until
years after my schooling that doing
university mathematics that it came to
me that I realize now I was doing visual
thinking and was actually doing
mathematics on that 5x5 grid of squares
I realized then that this bedroom
ceiling was actually my portal to true
mathematics and I would encourage you to
look for similar
opportunity perhaps you too have ceiling
tiles or wallpaper pattern or parquet
floor or a tiled floor something you
look at every day and once you start
looking for these patterns you'll be
amazed how many you'll find so to
explain the puzzle the one that made me
a mathematician I work on an actual grid
of squares with you so let's head on
over and do a demonstration ok here it
is my bedroom ceiling a 5x5 grid of
squares and here's the puzzle I invented
for myself that I truly believe made me
a mathematician it goes as follows so I
chose a starting spot so let's say I
chose the top-left corner and the game I
played for myself was can I walk a path
that visits each and every cell exactly
once just moving horizontally and
vertically for example I can actually do
it this one does work so I'll start here
mark my starting spot and maybe I'll do
a whole bunch of horizontal steps first
maybe then one down step vertical then
maybe another bunch of horizontal steps
so now I keep going this way
a little bit crazy but I can definitely
find a path that does indeed visit each
cell exactly once great that was
starting from the top left corner now to
do from different position well let's
try it let's find out say how about
starting from the middle of the side can
I find a path that visits every cell
exactly once well let's try it
ah kind of random here just get going
and do something like this am i ok Oh
looking just fine great
alright loads of fun so I just kept
going in fact let's just another spot
say choose the very middle one all right
I'm gonna do it cuz I think but I think
I can see an answer right away what if I
just did a spiral can you see that's
going to work huh so the middle position
works as well but then here's the thing
I chose a different square like this one
and matters seem to change I'm gonna try
this one so maybe I'll start by going up
a vertical step maybe we'll go over and
I can do something like this it looks
pretty good maybe I'll come down a
little zigzag okay so far so good maybe
I'll come round like this
I'm not nervous yet looks fine oh now
I'm getting a bit nervous I go up here
I've got to get to that cell not miss it
but good all these over here so maybe
I'll do them but then I'm stuck I could
do I'd a diagonal step but I won't allow
that my game was only vertical and
horizontal steps so this cell this one I
guess what is it one in from the middle
was questionable in fact I tried it lots
of different ways maybe I do is
something more like this and I - Lea
stuck that as a young lads I kept doing
this I always got stuck on that one well
let me try it another one are there
other cells that make you stuck for
example let's try oh no this one here we
haven't done that one yet well let's do
it give it a go see what happens so this
feels fine so far so I've got that half
of the board done all that two-fifths of
the board maybe do something like this
and get this portion of the board done
looks good so far actually this is great
let me keep going oh now I'm starting to
get nervous because I kind of want to do
something like I they go up here and I
come over and I've got a choice left or
right I'm gonna get stuck so maybe I
should do this but then I'm forced to go
up there and I got a choice again I'm
gonna get stuck and go one way but not
reach the other way hmm so this cell
here is troublesome as well all right so
now let's be a little systematic here
some cells would definitely yes I could
do it because I did it that we've done
here so let me get a clean grid yet
again and what I'll do now is I'll be
little systematic and mark the cells
that were yeses for example that cell
that was the very first example we tried
yes we definitely could find a path
visiting every cell exactly once with
horizontal and vertical steps starting
there oh I should let's be clever we
altered this corner cell as a yes what
about this corner cell must that be a
yes as well if you think about it
actually yes whatever solution we have
here just take your solution and turn it
around 90 degrees and that'll be a
solution for the top right corner so if
the top-left corner is a yes the top
right corner must also be yes oh and
then take that solution
another 90 degrees that means this
corner is a yes as well in fact all four
corners must be yes cells I said only
four corners are yeses in this picture
we did the middle cell next that was yes
where she did it
that little spiral was fine what else we
did we did the middle cell of a side if
I remember
so that was a yes ah but then by
symmetry again rotating 90 degrees means
this was a yes this was a yes and this
was a yes all right looks pretty but any
more yeses in this picture hmm well
right now we do have a couple of
question marks now we tried this one and
I don't tried it once today but I
actually tried that cell for years as a
kid and I could never do it but it must
have been a strange child because I
never actually said the answer is no
because I realized maybe I just didn't
try hard enough if I kept going maybe
I'll stumble upon the solution
eventually so I just was honest I said
this is still a question to me my gut
told me it's probably in no cell but I
put a question mark nonetheless also we
questioned this one I think we tried
that one earlier so that was a question
we'll sell as well
oh then by symmetry if this cell is
questionable rotate 90 degrees means
that this cell is also questionable
because I've had a solution for this one
just rotate it 90 degrees back and I
would have had a solution to that one as
well in fact I can argue all of these
four cells here are questionable in fact
again 90 degree rotation this one gets
me where is it here so that must be
questionable Nigeria rotation
questionable and questionable now I'm
starting to fill in the grid Oh actually
doing more symmetry if this cell is
questionable then I bet if I just
reflect the image this cell must also be
questionable because if I had a solution
here somehow they'll just reflect back
and that would have given me a solution
there so this cell must also be
questionable and I guess by magically
symmetry all the side cells that are
left over are also questionable all
right okay so then I was doing some
systematic work here but we see these
four cells we haven't tried yet all
right can they be done or can they not
be done well let's try it
so I'll start here
that's the right one is it yep and see
if I can do a path that visits every
cell exactly once with vertical and
horizontal steps and I'm just trying it
out here not sure where I'm going so far
no pickles everything's looking fine do
I look okay look at that it can be done
that's a yes by rotational symmetry
that's a yes that's a yes that's a yes
all right I know for sure that these Y's
are definitely yes cells because we
actually did it but the puzzle for me
was are these questionable cells
actually just questions could they be
done if I tried harder or they really
knows and that is the question that's
stuck with me for years
are they really no cells my gut was
telling me they really were cuz I tried
it lots and lots and lots and lots of
times it can never do it but I wanted
the logic behind it why would they be no
cells maybe I just need to try one more
time okay so that question statement
with me for I know good six or seven
years and I remember walking to school
in grade 10 one day not particularly
thinking about this problem and a
strange wondrous epiphany just hit me
out of the blue I suddenly saw a logical
reason why these question marks had to
be no cells so I'm gonna give away my
epiphany now I'm going to give away the
result that just makes it glaringly
obvious wipe these and knows okay so you
want to wait for the pivot yourself
maybe want to pause for a moment and
just go for a walk or something because
I'm bout to give it away right fair
warning
so look at what we've got here have you
noticed that the Y's and the question
marks make a checkerboard pattern hmm in
fact let me really make it obvious the
checkerboard pattern so I actually color
it in some cells just like a
checkerboard so I've got some purple
cells and I'll have some white cells all
right and look at that how many purple
cells are there well let's count them
one two three four five one two three
four five that makes 10 and one two
three
so purple cells number in 13 and the
white cells then must be twelve of them
because there's 25 cells at all one two
three four five one two three four five
one two the white cells come in 12 a set
of 12 all right so what well notice all
the question marks and the locations of
these white cells so I'm wondering why
would it be impossible to start a path
on a white cell let's think about it I'm
on a white cell so maybe our first cell
is what I'll actually write down W for
my first cell is white whichever white
cell I'm in I've got no choice but to
next walk in to a purple cell whichever
direction I go the next cell has to be
purple okay if I'm in a purple cell I
must next go to number where I am into a
white cell I want to min a white cell I
must x go to a purple then white then
purple then white then purple then white
then purple then white then purple okay
how many steps is that one two three
four five six seven eight nine 10 11 12
okay it's only 12 of the steps what I
keep going wipe the purple white then
purple white then purple white then
purple white then purple white then
purple that's 24 okay
there's 25 cells of they have to take
one more step Oh
currently in a purple cell and I have to
take one more step that we have a
problem
look there are 12 white cells and 13
purple cells and right now I've used up
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve whites and I've
only used up twelve Purple's we still
have an extra purple to go which means
I'm in a pickle because the next step
I've only got a purple to use but it
can't be purple because if it's purple
I'm in trouble I meant to go to a white
cell next that's impossible you cannot
start in a white cell because you run
out of the white cells before use them
used up all the purple cells but the
only way this puzzle could possibly work
so that extra purple cell appears at the
beginning for this puzzle to work you
must start on a purple cell and look
indeed we could do it if we did isn't
that beautiful
that was an epiphany that maybe say wow
there's something going on in this
universe it's just beautiful
okay we're still only scratching the
of things let's push play with us 5x5
grid even further there are more
surprises in store but this time let's
view the 5x5 grid as an array of dots
now stare at this picture it is
certainly a picture of 25 dots but can
you see in this picture the sum 1 + 2 +
3 + 4 + 5 + 4 + 3 + 2 + 1 now it takes a
moment it takes an epiphany here goes
look at the diagonals 1 2 3 4 5 4 3 2 1
the sum we seek matches the diagonals of
the square there are 25 dots and all so
without doing a lick of arithmetic we
can say the value of the sum must be 25
I love this this picture is powerful and
it speaks beyond its literal self what
is the sum of the numbers 1 2 3 all the
way up to 10 and back down again well
this sum must come from the diagonals of
a 10 by 10 array of dots and again
without a liquor of arithmetic the value
of the sum must be 10 squared 100 so ok
here's the power what is the sum of all
the numbers from 1 up to a thousand and
back down again well it must be a
thousand squared from a thousand by a
thousand array of dots thousand squared
is a million imagine trying to compute
that on a calculator 1 + 2 + 3 + 4 all
over after a thousand and back down
again it would take forever the picture
here is mightier than the machine
the answer is available to us in the
blink of an eye via this picture some of
the numbers one to a thousand back down
again is a thousand squared from a
thousand five thousand array of dots ok
so what who cares about these sums
well actually school curricula do in my
high school days we had to memorize a
general formula for the sum of numbers
the formula looked like this the sum of
the first n numbers 1 + 2 + 3 all up to
some number n is N squared plus n all
divided by 2
example the sum of the first five
numbers 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 is
5 square plus 5 25 plus 5 that's 30 then
divided by 2 is 15 and one can check
that 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 is
indeed 15 of course as students we
wanted to know where this formula is
coming from why is it true
those were the burning questions down
mines not just applying the formula to
all the counting problems in my textbook
so how can we get this formula
well our 5x5 array of dots gave us
something akin to this result we have
there that 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5
plus 4 plus 3 plus 2 plus 1 is 25 can we
get from this just the answer to 1 plus
2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 here's the lovely
thing about doing mathematics it's
mostly about mulling and then following
your nose if you look at what we have we
see that the Sun we want one plus two
plus three plus four plus five is the
left half of our equation well I said
half that's not quite right the right
portion of the equation is missing a
five that's annoying it's just the sum 1
plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 wouldn't be lovely
to see 1 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 on
that right half there as well here's a
piece of general advice then if there's
something a life you want just make it
happen and we'll be floating the splice
a lot in these lectures we want to see
an additional 5 so let's make it happen
let's add a 5 on the left and to keep
things balanced we need to add a 5 on
the right as well lovely now we see two
copies of what we want twice the sum we
seek is 25 plus 5 so this means the sum
itself is half of this 1 plus 2 Plus 3
plus 4 plus 5 is indeed 5 squared plus 5
divided by 2 and this matches the
general formula I had to memorize and
there's nothing special about the number
5 here the same ideas show the sum of
the numbers from 1 up to n the sum of
the first end counting numbers that is
must be half of N squared plus n there
we have it
but let's keep going in mathematics
there really is no such thing as being
done with an idea or concept or a
picture look at the fire by five grid of
dots again this time let me ask do you
see the sum one plus three plus five
plus seven plus nine the sum of the
first five ordered numbers well the
answer is yes as we can certainly circle
these groups randomly and make them fit
but such a random picture isn't
enlightening we want to see a picture
that isn't locked into this particular
example of 25 dots we want a picture
that actually speaks to a higher truth
and clearly holds for all possible
square arrays mathematicians are always
on the lookout for this sort of thing
and symmetry is often a pointer to
higher truths and we'll see the
incredible power of symmetry throughout
this course in particular when we come
to completely revolutionize some
standard high school algebra with the
power symmetry in a couple of later
lectures but back to the matters at hand
do you see 1 plus 3 plus 5 / 7 plus 9
and a 5x5 array of dots in a way that
speaks to a higher truth well it takes
another PIFAN e this time think L shapes
some of the first five old numbers is
hidden in the five by five array as LS
the sum one plus three plus five plus
seven plus nine must be five squared all
twenty-five dots 25 in the same way the
sum of the first ten odd numbers 1 plus
3 plus 5 / 7 plus 9 plus 11 plus 13 plus
15 - 17 plus 19 sit in a 10 by 10 array
of dots and so must have the answer 100
the count of dots in that array in
general the sum of the first n odd
numbers must be N squared whoa
actually let me show you something
stunning that Galileo notice about the
odd numbers Galileo revered today for
his work in astronomy and physics and
science and mathematics in general
Galileo thought to make fractions out of
the odd numbers and will play with
fractions in a few lectures time for
example take the first 5 odd numbers and
use their sum for the numerator of a
fraction
and the some of the next five numbers
for the denominator this gives a
fraction that simplifies to 1/3 okay but
do the same thing for the first two odd
numbers followed by the next two you get
1/3 again do it again for the first 10
odd numbers followed by the next 10 and
it's one-third yet again Galileo
observed that all the fractions made out
of the odd numbers this way are equal
they all equal 1/3 these fractions today
called the Galilean ratios when I share
this observation with some high school
students back in 2009 they immediately
saw a connection between the ratios and
the L shapes and squares here's their
purely visual proof of the Galilean
ratios here the first 5 L shapes the sum
of the first five numbers make one block
of 25 dots the next 5 L shapes for the
next 5 or numbers makes three blocks of
25 dots so the first 5 odd numbers make
for 1/3 of the next 5 or numbers just
beautiful next lecture we'll see how
these students got negative numbers into
these fraction ratios to amazing stuff
all right now this focus on odd numbers
is grand but my gut a little perturbed
by this lopsided focus on matters other
results about sums of even numbers as
well example we have a picture of the
sum of the first 500 us can we get from
this of some of the first 5 even numbers
2 plus 4 / 6 plus 8 plus 10 well just
add a dot to each l-shape fabulous this
has turned the 5x5 square into a
rectangle the sum or the first five even
numbers must be the five by five we had
before plus five more five square plus 5
which is 30 in general the sum of the
first n even numbers must come from the
picture of N squared dots plus an extra
and dots N squared plus n now as a
mathematician I'm feeling good I feel
we're coming full circle as we've seen
the expression ends
plus n before take the sum of the first
five numbers
it equals five squared plus five now
divide everything by 2 2 divided by 2 4
divided by 2 6 / 2 8 and 10 each divided
by 2 and finally 5 squared is 5 divided
by 2 and we're back to the formula 1
plus 2 Plus 3 plus 4 plus 5 equals 5
square plus 5 all over 2 so indeed we
have come full circle we're back to the
formula I had to memorize back in school
everything is hanging together so
beautifully all feels symmetrical robust
and pleasing so that is the goal of this
course to show how mathematics is seen
the right way and I really do mean seen
can become robust and complete and
pleasing and with that a sense of
ownership emerges the confidence to play
with ideas develops and mathematics
transforms from the experience of hazy
thinking and memorization to powerful
clarity insight and fun as we've done
this lecture we'll look at topics that
might be familiar from school days and
general reading and push them to heights
of joyful understanding and we'll also
explore topics that might not be
familiar at all now there is a general
flow to the sequence of topics we'll
follow from counting like we did today
to numbers and infinity to algebra and
clever mathematical applications but the
flow is loose so feel free to bounce
around between lectures that takes your
fancy I am so excited let's get cracking